THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
ME.
>>> ALSO HERE WITH US TONIGHT
IS JOSH HAWLEY.
SENATOR, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
ME TODAY.
PASSIONATE CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
BUT WHAT THE REPUBLICAN
RESPONSE NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE.
SO, YOU ARE A RISING STAR.
YOU ARE CONSIDERED ONE OF THE
LEADERS IN THE NEW G.O.P.
WHAT DO YOU PROPOSE?
>> Senator: HOW ABOUT
BRINGING JOBS BACK TO THE
URBAN CORE FROM OVERSEAS?
START THERE.
START WITH THE DISASTROUS
TRADE POLICIES AND THE
ECONOMIC POLICIES THAT THE
LIBERALS IN-STEP WITH THE BIG
CORPORATIONS PURSUED FOR 30,
40 YEARS.
WHO IS HURT MOST?
WORKING FOLKS.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WORKING
FOLKS.
LATINO WORKING FOLKS.
WHITE WORKING FOLKS.
ASIAN WORKING FOLKS.
YOU NAME IT.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT THE
COMMUNITIES SUFFERED AS THE
JOBS ARE SHIPPED OFF TO CHINA
AND SHIPPED OVERSEAS TO THE
LOWER BIDDER AND THE LOWEST
WAGES.
THE DEMOCRATS MADE AMERICAN
WORKER COMPETE WITH THE SLAVE
LABOR.
THEY HAVE DONE IT TO GET RICH.
SO THE BIG CORPORATIONS CAN
GET RICH.
TIME TO BRING IT BACK TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITY IN THE
URBAN CORE, EVERYWHERE FOR THE
AMERICAN WORKERS.
THAT IS WHERE I WOULD START.
>> IT STARTS THERE.
BUT RESPECTFULLY THE AUDIENCE
ALREADY KNOW ABOUT THAT.
THEY WATCH FOX.
WE DISCUSS THIS EVERY DAY.
HOW DO YOU GET NEW PEOPLE IN?
I GOT TO TELL YOU.
YOU GUYS JUST LOST GEORGIA.
PART OF IT WAS BECAUSE YOU GUY
DID NOT ATTRACT NEW VOTERS.
SO HOW DO YOU TAKE THAT
MESSAGE AND TELL IT TO THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE NOT
REACHING?
>> Senator: WE HAVE TO BE
THE PARTY OF THE WORKING
PEOPLE IN THE NATION.
LOOK AT HOW TRUMP GREW THE
PARTY IN 2016 AND 2020.
AND MADE IT THE MOST RACIALLY
DIVERSE BACKGROUND, THE
RACIALLY DIVERSE NUMBER OF THE
VOTES THAT IS PRESIDENT,
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT HAS
GOTTEN SINCE 1960.
THAT WAS TRUMP’S RECORD.
SINCE 1960.
HOW DID HE DO IT?
HE FOCUSED ON THE CONCERNS OF
THE WORKING PEOPLE.
WORKING AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
WORKING LATINO VOTERS AND
WORKING WHITES, WORKING FOLKS.
WE HAVE TO BE THE PARTY OF
WORKING PEOPLE AND BE THE
PARTY TO GET JOBS BACK IN THE
U.N. CO.
WE HAVE TO BE A PARTY OF
HIGHER WAGES FOR WORKING
PEOPLE.
BE THE PARTY OF THE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKERS TO
GET JOB TRAINING AND SKILLS
TRAINING WITHOUT HAVING TO GO
PAY AN EXPENSIVE FOUR-YEAR
EDUCATION THEY DON’T WANT.
IF WE ARE NOT THE PARTY OF
WORKING PEOPLE, WE WON’T HAVE
A FUTURE AS A PARTY.
THAT IS WHAT DONALD TRUMP
SHOWN US AND THAT IS PATH
FORWARD.
>> WHAT IS YOUR FUTURE?
ARE YOU RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT?
>> I AM NOT.
MY JOB IS TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF MISSOURI.
WE’RE A STATE, DIVERSE STATE
WITH THE WORKING FOLK, OF ALL
RACIAL BACKGROUNDS ACROSS OUR
STATE, MY STATE.
WE NEED POLICIES TO BRING THE
JOBS BACK TO THIS COUNTRY.
IMMIGRATION IS ANOTHER ONE.
WE HAVE TO CIT PRIORITIZING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS OVER THE
AMERICAN WORKERS.
WE NEED A PRO JOB, PRO WORKER
POLICY IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> I GOT TO TELL YOU, SENATOR.
IT SOUNDS GOOD.
WE WILL BE WATCHING YOU.
THIS AUDIENCE WILL BE WATCHING
YOU.
WE HOPE TO HAVE YOU BACK SOON.